there are lots of stars that you will
talk to at the BT Awards but I'm going
to show you a future star this young man
right here he's gonna get to the league
one day trust me write it one way or the
other your daddy's gonna get you there
cayenne Anthony hey you're you're in
lots of videos on the web working out
with your dad how how much fun is that
he works so hard dedicated discipline I
could a lot of people could learn a lot
from this kid yeah including myself I
love that that you're in the gym working
every single day I want to ask you about
nine oh two one oh right off the bat
because you got added to the cast
already you will be Brendan's
wife Brian Austin Green wife his wife
and it's been amazing we're in Vancouver
shooting now so I just shot here for
this and I got to go back to Vancouver
but it's been such an amazing show and
to be the only non original cast member
me and Vanessa Lachey it's just amazing
Wow it that's what I was gonna say I
hear it's kind of a twist and play on it
I was up there and everybody was so
excited I was there the day they
announced you and everybody was so
excited about you coming to join that
guy that makes me happy so be on the
lookout for that and it's the final
season of power getting into that right
now
we're getting there easy now okay every
there are so many questions with power
and we know they'll be spin-offs what
can you tell us and who's surviving and
who's not because I think that's the big
question
oh I can't tell you guys I'll be fired
so let me tell you this it's the final
season it's gonna be a rollercoaster
ride the craziest stuff imaginable is
gonna happen so you gotta tune in August
25th one stars it's gonna be crazy what
about a spinoff you never know if
Lakeisha made it out or not you got to
stay tuned to find out
Lakeisha Tommy everybody wants to know
will that Tommy relationship come back
around it's there and it's as
dysfunctional as ever so be on the
lookout for that Wow okay we cannot wait
for Lakeisha and Tommy another question
I have to ask this young man right here
your daddy can shoot but clearly you are
putting up jumpers now who is the better
shooter in the family I'm gonna let you
say right there to the camera you can
outshoot your day
don't let his dad hear that I know okay
Melo just so you know the greatest
shooter in your family is standing next
to me I'll see you in the league I'll be
covering it then don't worry
[Music]